en Nueva Delhi Ismael can sigue llorando
la pérdida de su hermana fallecida hace
un año
Esta es mi hermana muscán murió en un
incendio trabajaba en una fábrica esta
foto Desde cuando iba a la escuela era
modelo Cuando miro esta foto la he hecho
mucho de menos
[Música]
14 de mayo de 2022 se declara un
incendio en esta planta de ensamblaje de
productos electrónicos en el oeste de
Nueva Delhi 27 personas perdieron la
vida según varios testigos el edificio
no tenía salida de emergencia solo una
puerta de entrada bloqueada por cajas de
cartón para Ismael los propietarios de
la fábrica fueron los principales
responsables de la tragedia si la
empresa donde se produjo el incendio
hubiera tenido una puerta de salida
adicional todo el mundo habría podido
escapar nadie habría muerto en segundo
lugar la mayor culpa es de los dos
propietarios de la fábrica cuando se
hicieron cargo de esta fábrica no tenía
puerta de salida no había certificados
de cumplimiento de las normas ni
instalaciones esenciales
la fábrica funcionaba ilegalmente
y su familia han emprendido acciones
legales y están a la espera de juicio
India el país más poblado del mundo ha
emprendido una carrera hacia el
desarrollo industrial por todas partes
surgen edificios y fábricas en India los
accidentes laborales son cotidianos y
los trabajadores pobres son las primeras
víctimas
en gasia abad en los suburbios de Nueva
Delhi enclavada en una zona industrial
oculta a la vista una fábrica de piezas
de grifería ha accedido a abrirnos sus
puertas
Esta es nuestra sala de máquinas donde
fabricamos los grifos y accesorios
es el Guardián del lugar
en este pequeño taller no hay salidas de
emergencia ni extintores las
instalaciones eléctricas son obviamente
peligrosas y los barrotes y la basura
bloquean todas las ventanas para los
trabajadores ni guantes ni zapatos de
seguridad ni mascarilla cuando
preguntamos a mujeres por la seguridad
de sus empleados el director de la
empresa prefiere pasar la
responsabilidad al Estado Indio
si el gobierno diera recursos a los
empresarios para la salud y el bienestar
de los trabajadores
estos podrían sentirse más cómodos en el
trabajo y aumentar su capacidad de
producción
aquí 17 empleados trabajan seis días a
la semana no se nos permitió preguntarle
su opinión sobre las condiciones de
trabajo Según la ley India todas fabrica
con más de 10 empleados debe tener un
comité de seguridad una norma que rara
vez se aplica en el país cada año miles
de trabajadores del sector mueren o
quedan discapacitados como consecuencia
de accidentes laborales
el Ministerio de trabajo indio Calcula
que una media de tres personas ha muerto
en accidentes laborales cada día en los
últimos años una encuesta independiente
realizada en 2017 eleva la cifra a 131
en el este de Delhi ramsant lleva ocho
meses postrado en cama y gravemente
herido el pasado agosto una botella de
ácido le explotó por todo el cuerpo en
el almacén de productos químicos donde
trabajaba
he perdido el conocimiento Me he quedado
ciego
no soy capaz de ver dónde está ni qué
aspecto tiene
el dueño de la empresa no ha venido a
verme ni una sola vez desde el accidente
y esta empresa ni siquiera me pagaban
100 euros al mes Ahora quiero justicia
soy muy pobre mi hija está en edad de
casarse
y ahora estoy ciego mi cuerpo ya no me
sirve para nada
[Música]
desde el accidente la familia no tiene
recursos económicos
he pedido prestamos aquí allá para
alimentar a mi familia a veces pido
cinco o diez euros para Mis parientes el
alquiler de la casa también ha aumentado
estoy muy endeudada tenía una propiedad
en mi pueblo pero la vendí llevamos un
año viviendo con esta tragedia
y su familia carecen de asistencia
jurídica en la capital India una
organización internacional intenta dar
voz a estos trabajadores vulnerables
a purga es secretaria Regional del
sindicato industrial
denuncia las nuevas leyes del código
laboral indio que acaban de aprobarse y
que podrían debilitar aún más la
protección de los trabajadores
lo que está ocurriendo ahora es que hay
un cambio por parte del gobierno se
pondrán fin a las inspecciones
aleatorias No planificadas ni anunciadas
a partir de ahora los inspectores
informarán a la dirección de la empresa
Cuando vengan a inspeccionarla esto no
es algo que contribuya a la seguridad de
los trabajadores
el gobierno ha anunciado otros proyectos
de ley entre las medidas previstas sólo
las fábricas con más de 250 empleados
estarán obligadas a tener un comité de
seguridad frente a los 10 que había
anteriormente una reforma también
criticada por los sindicatos